ja meine damen und herren wir sollten
endlich damit anfangen unser eigenes
leben zu leben auch wenn wir dazu die
gesellschaft von grund auf umkrempeln
müssen
das fordert mein heutiger gast der
schweizer remo largo hat sein leben
unsere zukunft gewidmet nämlich den
kindern zunächst aus acht später
ausforschen und als erziehungsratgeber
viele von ihnen die selbst kinder haben
kennen sicher sein buch babyjahre ein
standardwerk über die kindliche
entwicklung in den ersten vier jahren in
den nächsten tagen nun erscheint sein
neuestes buch das er selbst als sein
lebenswerk bezeichnet was passende leben
darüber wollen wir heute sprechen er lag
auf herzlich willkommen vielen dank für
die einladung und ich fühle mich auf das
gespann ich auch ja das passende leben
was ist denn ein passendes leben darf
ich etwas aus greift gerne die die ganze
evolution eigentlich aller leben
lebewesen besteht darin dass sie sich
unablässig an ihre umgebung angepasst
haben also sie haben eine eine
übereinstimmung gesucht mit der umwelt
und das gilt jetzt nicht nur für eine
tierart oder einem konsulat oder die
menschen sondern es gilt für den
einzelnen auch auch im kleinen also wir
sind eigentlich das ganze leben lang
bemüht in übereinstimmung mit der umwelt
zu leben
und da ist eben die große frage erlaubt
aus die umwelt überhaupt noch also die
gesellschaft und die wirtschaft
das klingt jetzt so also ich und die
umwelt wir müssen irgendwie
übereinstimmen
er muss ich denn da neben ammann passen
muss ich mich jetzt der gesellschaft
anpassen einer umwelt oder umgekehrt
also der einzelne macht das ja
unablässig und das ist auch eine
herausforderung die man nicht delegieren
kann also das muss jeder für sich selber
lösen und die große schwierigkeit ist
dass jeder mensch einzigartig ist also
eher kann das nur für sich selber machen
es gibt keine regeln
darauf haben sie vielleicht mich
angesprochen
keine regung wie man das leisten könnte
sondern man geht von seinen eigenen
bedürfnissen von seinen eigenen
fähigkeiten und vorstellungen aus und
versucht dann die in übereinstimmung mit
der umwelt zu bringen und das problem
ist einfach die umwelt kann natürlich so
gestaltet sein dass das im einzelnen gar
nicht mehr möglich ist
aber es geht schon darum eigentlich ein
leben zu finden das zu mir als person zu
meine individuellen persönlichkeit passt
genau ist denn das heute schwieriger als
früher oder einfach weil man könnte ja
sagen ihre generation hat sich viele
freiheiten erkennt den 60er und 70er
jahren die technologie macht enorme
fortschritte wir haben mehr
möglichkeiten ist es heute einfach das
passende leben zu finden
also ich gehe von sechs gruppe durch
flüsse aus und ich beschränke mich jetzt
auf 2 1 ein wichtiges grundbedürfnis ist
dass man sich geborgen und genommen
fühlt und dafür braucht man die familie
und eine umwelt vertraute menschen also
in einer anonymen massengesellschaft
kann man sich nicht geborgen fühlen das
ist eines der ganz großen probleme
heutzutage
dass wir im grunde genommen nicht mehr
diese vertraute umgebung haben also uns
fehlt vor allem als er die kleine
familie ist entstanden oder also auch da
ist sind ist die anzahl vertrauter
personen kleiner geworden und dann vor
allem ist die lebensgemeinschaft dass
eine gemeinschaft sagen wir von 50 bis
300 menschen die an wirklich für 13 ein
leben lang
das ist weitgehend verschwunden also so
wie man früher in großfamilien gelebt
hat oder auf den dort zum beispiel das
gibt es heute immer reden also die ich
ahne schon das ganze hat auch
gesellschaftliche politische
konsequenzen wenn wir sagen würden wir
müssen das leben leben das zu uns passt
damit wir unsere grundbedürfnisse
ausleben befriedigen können lassen sie
uns später noch über diese
gesellschaftlichen konsequenzen sprechen
jetzt am anfang interessiert mich mal
wenn ich das passende leben suchen muss
ich mich selbst erstmal kennen ihn
kennenlernen wie geht denn das
eigentlich selbsterkenntnis
also ich kann nur eine vermutung
anstellen ich würde jetzt meinen dass
man sich da sind der vergangenheit
allerdings nicht gefragt hat und weil
weil man irgendwie dann ist das gegangen
aber in unserer gesellschaft und das ist
er überall so und wirkt sich dann auch
in einer unzahl von ratgebern aus oder
in unserer gesellschaft und das ist
vielleicht das erste mal überhaupt in
der menschheitsgeschichte muss man sich
irgendwie klar werden was man selbst ist
also was ist manchmal bin ich als in den
dom
und da gibt es natürlich schon gewisse
vorstellungen aber ich habe dann
versucht irgendwie das so weiter zu
führen dass man einerseits sagen kann
also ich habe bestimmte gruppe dürfte
und ich hab andererseits bestimmte
fähigkeiten und ich habe mich ja ein
leben lang mit kindern beschäftigt und
da ist es unendlich viel leichter zu
sehen wie sich diese grundbedürfnisse
entwickeln wie sich die fähigkeiten
entwickeln und wie man dann den
erwachsenen nimmt oder aber letztlich
denke ich ist es der boxen natürlich
nicht grundsätzlich verschieden sind ihm
aber ich nehme an sie kennen sich selbst
frage wie haben sie sich kennengelernt
sitzt man zu hause auf dem sofa forscht
in sich hinein
oder mach mal eine reise spricht man mit
freunden geht man zum psychiater
psychologen wen fragt man wer kennt mich
eigentlich am besten
ich denke auf dem lebensweg wird man
irgendwie gezwungen sich zu hinterfragen
weil man hat erfolgt dann fragt man sich
warum wurde es geht nicht dann fragt man
sich noch viel mehr warum geht das alles
nicht aber das ist dann schwierig
irgendwie zu verstehen worum dass es
nicht geht also häufig versucht man dann
einfach etwas anderes ruft das dass man
mir dieses mal folgt also ihre frage
zielt nicht darauf ab
wie kann man seine eigenen gruppe durch
schlüsse irgendwie erfassen und seine
fähigkeiten erfassen und das läuft oft
aus hinaus und ich würde meinen die
wenigsten tun das gern weil sie gegen
die angst haben dass sie sich dann
festlegen müssen also dass
sie einfach dann realisieren eigentlich
ist ein bestimmtes grundbedürfnis ganz
anders als ich mir gedacht ob er eine
frage oder dass man etwas entdeckt das
sagen nicht gefällt ja und ich habe in
unserer gesellschaft so eine wirklich
dringliche frage ist gehen wir nicht nur
die gesellschaft die wirtschaft sondern
der einzelne mit seinen grenzen um dass
man die akzeptiert und und nicht
irgendeine einer traumwelt nachhängt
oder eine mito sondern dass man
eigentlich den versuch die
grundbedürfnisse möglichst gut zu
befriedigen und die erfahrung ist durch
die wenn einem das einigermaßen gelingt
dann ist man zufrieden
also zu sagen man sei glücklich finde
ich hoch gegriffen aber man man ist
zufrieden also zum beispiel wenn man
eine leistung selbständiger bringen kann
die einem entspricht dass man die
eigenen ziele erreicht sie haben es
schon angetönt krisen tiefpunkte können
wichtig sein für die selbsterkenntnis
können sie das persönlich bestätigen
also in meinem leben war das sehr so
oder so zb das ich wirklich schwere
gesundheitliche krisen hatte mehrmals
und dass die mich dann auf ein lebensweg
gezwungen haben den ich eigentlich gar
nicht vorhatte das glück bei mir war
einfach dass das es eigentlich
langfristig dann immer gut ausgekommen
ist also zum beispiel ich hatte nach dem
studium hatte ich schwierige
gesundheitliche situation ich habe die
schindeln konnte nicht mehr stehen
ich habe mein gehör verloren und um das
war so ein halbes jahr ist ein jahr war
ich in berlin
ich wollte ursprünglich kinderarzt
kinderchirurg werden dass conti fest
januar die frage was mache ich jetzt und
so bin ich dann auf diese abteilung
gekommen
im kinderspital die sich hauptsächlich
mit der entwicklung der kinder
beschäftigt hatte und das habe ich mir
doch und zuvor aber ich denke das war
eigentlich eine glückliche fügung in
auch in ein persönliches schicksal das
sie dann auf einen anderen lebensweg
gebracht hat jetzt haben sie schon
mehrmals diese grundbedürfnisse des
menschen angesprochen und wir haben hier
ein grafik vorbereitet die diese sechs
grundbedürfnisse zeigt warum also unter
den meisten kann man sich glaube ich
etwas vorstellen ich habe mich gefragt
warum genau diese 6 vorher haben sie das
warum nicht sieben warum nicht fünf
eigentlich zehn ja das habe ich mich
jahrelang gefragt und das war ein einweg
oder also der reduktion und ich gehe
eigentlich davon aus dass das es keine
wesentlichen bedürfnisse gibt die über
das hinausgehen
wissen sie was mich überrascht hat dass
der punkt leistung leistung als
grundbedürfnis ja das heißt dass das ist
enorm wichtig also wir bringen nicht nur
leistungen um soziale anerkennung zu
bekommen das natürlich auch ein punkt
ist ja ja aber eigentlich will jeder
mensch seinen fähigkeiten einsetzen und
damit eine leistung erbringen und das
befriedigt
und da kann man dann sagen ja wie kommt
dass das kommt daher dass natürlich im
verlaufe der menschheitsgeschichte
diejenigen die dieses bedürfnis hatten
mehr leistung erbracht hatten und auch
gewissermaßen im vorteil waren oder dass
sie sie konnten das leben besser
meistern also hat sich im verlauf der
menschheitsgeschichte hat sich dieses
bedürfnis an ausgebildet dass man
leistung erbringen will und das ist
können wir vielleicht später noch dran
das ist heute in der wirtschaft ein ganz
großes buch jetzt ist es so dass alle
menschen diese sechs grundbedürfnisse
haben aber nicht in derselben weise
ausgeprägt also die sind unterschiedlich
akzentuiert könnte man sagen und sie
haben dazu ein solches netz diagramm in
ihrem buch und das sieht dann bei jedem
menschen anders also ich kann das
vielleicht mal vor machen jetzt auch
selbsteinschätzung von mir so sehr
schnell man überlegt sich körperliche
integrität wie wichtig ist es aber dass
gleich können sie einen satz dazu sagen
welche frage musste man sich darstellen
also wo man gesund ist natürlich aber
auch wie es das ist bei uns eine
selbstverständlichkeit wie man sich
ernähren kann das ist für milliarden von
menschen ist das nicht so dass ihm dass
sie eine körperliche integration haben
in dem sinne dass sie sich ausreichend
ernähren können wir haben vielmehr das
problem dass das wir eigentlich zu viel
essen also das übergewicht das heißt ein
weit verbreitetes problem geworden und
interessanterweise eben frauen deshalb
weil in der vergangenheit werden 200.000
ja war das kein thema also dass sich die
menschen ausreichend ernähren
das war eigentlich nie der fall also man
brauchte den hunger um sich zu ernähren
aber nicht eine bremse heute habe ich
einen überfluss und japan sind
es ist die natur so geschadet wie wir
uns heute haben haben sich die menschen
in der vergangenheit überhaupt nicht
also ich versuche das mal zu machen
übergewicht ist bei mir kein problem
trotzdem glaube ich dass körperliche
integrität gesundheit für mich ganz
wichtig ist geborgenheit zum beispiel
schätze ich jetzt bei mir selbst als
weniger wichtig ein anerkennung
vielleicht doch dafür vielleicht noch
etwas sorgen zu erwirken haid oder weil
das der nicht unbedingt einfach
abzugrenzen von der sozialen anerkennung
aber geborgen heißt heißt eigentlich
dass man in einer beziehung oder
beziehungen lebt die nur schwerlich in
frage gestellt werden also das kind
fühlt sich sowohl das nicht immer stimmt
aber es fühlt sich bedingungslos
angenommen das ist der klassiker
gewissermaßen ohne also das kind stellt
sich nie die frage lieben mich dir denn
es ist überzeugt die ich bin für sie das
wichtigste auf dieser werden
egal was ich kann und was ich tue genau
das ist ganz das ist das bedingungslose
also das sehe dann ungefähr so aus
angenommen ich selbst kann mich richtig
einschätzen
das ist natürlich auch noch die frage
wie sieht es denn bei ihnen als was ist
ihnen am wichtigsten
also aus dem was ich bereits etwas
gesagt und daran gewöhnt habe die
körperliche integrität ist für mich
extrem wichtig weil die wurde ein leben
lang immer wieder in frage gestellt
wenn ich mir jetzt überlegen wie war ich
als kind emotional abhängig oder
unabhängig konnte ich gut aber ein sein
dann würde ich meinen und das gilt auch
heute noch dass ich da auch einen hohen
bedeutung sozialer anerkennung und
stellung
das möge jetzt erstaunen das würde ich
nicht so hoch einschätzen soziale
stellung heißt ja unter anderem welche
bedeutung misst man zum beispiel der
stellung ein die man in der arbeiter
aber eben bei mir jetzt wie bekannt bin
ich also das ist schwer vielleicht
schwer zu glauben aber das ist nicht so
dass das bei mir ich schreibe bücher
nicht führt aus sondern ist schreibt sie
für das was ich bin ein getriebener
ich bin mental das ist da nicht
irgendwie mir selbst geschuldet oder das
will ich sondern ich kann nicht anders
und das hat schon in der pubertät
angefangen und das treibt mich einfach
an also es ist es ist wirklich nicht
eine frage der freiheit unter
entscheidung aber das ist so
das ist kein zwang haben sie gesagt ja
getrieben ja ja ja also ein musikrat mal
gesagt diese dieses bedürfnis noch
selbstentfaltung das ist kein können
sondern ein müssen und bei ihm ist das
verfahren die neugier hätte sich
neugierig beobachten konnte mich oft
selber dabei über die neugierde ja bei
der leistung habe ich würde ich meinen
auch einen hohen anspruch
also das war einer der gründe weshalb
ich dann am kinderspital eine abteilung
aufgebaut habe für kinder die
verhaltensauffälligkeiten und
entwicklungsstörungen hatte weil ich
einfach das gefühl hatte
da muss ich etwas beitragen
existenzielle sicherheit da bin ich mir
eigentlich nicht so sich also für das
eher niedrig schätzen aber das problem
ist wenn man selber ja gut situierten
ist oder nicht ständig ständig die
finanziellen sorgen hat dann ist das
irgendwie schwierig zu sagen vielleicht
würde ich in panik kommen oder wenn wenn
wenn sich meine lebenssituation
gravierend verändern wird
das könnte man das wieder verbinden und
für mich drängt sich jetzt die frage auf
kann sich diese struktur im laufe des
lebens verändern oder ist die von klein
auf festgelegt und bleibt die ungefähr
gleich also wir haben
langzeitstudien gemacht und also wir
haben die kinder verfolgt vom bilderbuch
bis sie ins erwachsenenalter zum teil
noch lang und ich würde meinen
grundsätzlich bleibt das gleiche
dies drückt sich unterschiedlich aus das
wirkt sich natürlich anders als bei
kindern aus bei erwachsenen und es wird
oft auch verändert durch die erfahrungen
die man machen was sie zum beispiel
selbstentfaltung das kann durchaus sein
dass zum beispiel ein kind aus einer
migrationsfamilie sich während der
schulzeit nicht so in falten kann wie es
eigentlich möchte oder sondern es
es fühlt sich irgendwie rum befriedigt
und schafften das aber mit etwas glück
und ethik im schicksal als erwachsene
und manchmal sind selbst sie überrascht
als guter menschenkenner der viel
erfahrung gemacht hat mit kindern
die haben einen kleinen beitrag
vorbereitet aus dem dock vielen
faszination entwicklung und da kommen
zwei zwillinge so nämlich die laura und
die sara benz und sie haben die von
klein auf beobachtet in ihren langzeit
studien und waren später dann überrascht
wie sie sich entwickelt haben
das sieht man dann provinz und beten
oder die single so viel vertrauen das
sie zukommt und dem glauben ist sehr
aktiv
das hat mich ja wirklich erstaunt die
auf einer hand ist okay spieler will das
jetzt sarah story wird das halte ich für
möglich da wartet oder wie immer ist
auch ihr vorsichtig zurückhaltend und
klare schnittstellen private sondern
verteidigen
ja es war für mich sehr spannend
also was passiert hatten ja dann eine
medaille gemacht und olympia in sotschi
und bei dallara dass der staat mich
nicht so sehr weil sie war motorisch
immer aktiv und uns sehr kräftig also
dass sie verteidigerin wird das
überrascht wenig natürlich schon auch
dass sie dann eine medaille machen
bei der sache war das nicht so weil
dieser sich sehr fein gebaut sie ist
zurückhaltend verschlossen und das sind
jetzt charakter eigenschaften die man
bei einer stürmerin wirklich nicht nicht
zu erwarten wird
aber sie hat das entscheidende grund
geschossen in sotschi
bei dem titel das passende leben habe
ich mich gefragt hat jeder mensch
eigentlich nur ein passendes leben
können sie noch etwas
also kann ich mir vorstellen dass ich
jetzt also ich bin jetzt 33 jahre alt
sie 73 hätten sie ein anderes passendes
leben leben können hätte ich mehrere
andere leben leben können die ich aus
passend empfunden hätte zu mir ja ich
denke schon aber das ist wiederum sehr
auf eine unterform welche erfahrungen
man zuvor gemacht hat also ich hatte
einen sehr guten freund der vater war er
verwaltungsratspräsident einer einer
großen in keines großen industriellen
komplexes also er musste an die eta war
in stent wird und dann also zu rückgang
der jüngste ist so in der schweiz eines
industriebetriebes und mit 38 gesagt so
jetzt ist schluss weil er irgendwie
gespürt hatte ich komme auf das falsche
geleise er hat mir die ziel studiert und
wurde haushalts ja das gibt es wir sind
halt nicht festgelegt aber ich glaube
wir werden oft festgelegt auf eine
falsches geleise und die die die
änderung kommt dann dadurch dass man
einfach spürt immer mehr spürt dass das
einem das nicht entspricht jetzt man
damals
man spürte sind auch diese
selbstbeobachtung diese selbst erkenne
das ist ganz wichtig sie haben ja
wollten früh eigentlich schon den
menschen verstehen und das neue buch ist
so etwas wie eine anthropologie eine
lehre vom menschen
sie haben dann medizin studiert und
schließlich ihr leben kann man sagen den
kindern gewidmet erst aus kinderarzt und
später auch ausforschen und leiter der
abteilung für wachstum und entwicklung
am kinderspital in zürich
sie haben selbst drei töchter und vier
enkelkinder die sie auch regelmäßig
sehen sind auch ein familienmensch
was fasziniert sie an kindern ich weiß
es nicht ich weiß es nicht aber es ist
wahrscheinlich das was mich überhaupt am
meisten fasziniert aber wenn sie mich
fragen warum ich weiß nicht was ich
schwimme regelmäßig dann gehe ich immer
etwas früher noch also nicht nur
schwimmen ins hallenbad sondern ich
sitze am halbe oder eine stunde da und
schaut den kindern schien ihr was
absolut faszinierend lernt man sich
selbst auch besser wenn man nur ja oder
ja also also das schlüssel zu dem was
sich in den büchern geschrieben habe und
auch in wieselburg
das sind die kinder das heißt es steckt
auch viel kind in uns erwachsenen also
manchmal denke ich wahrscheinlich eine
querung werde ich immer noch kein klingt
wir haben jetzt diese langzeitstudien
schon zweimal erwähnt diese longitudinal
studien die haben sie ein großes echo
gefunden sehr renommiert sie haben da
glaube ich über 900 kindern von der
geburt bis ins erwachsenenalter
begleitet und wir sehen hier ein paar
bilder dazu wie sie experimente machen
mit kindern also zwischen 1954 und 2005
haben sie insgesamt vier von diesen
langzeitstudien gemacht an der abteilung
für wachstum und entwicklung und haben
die kinder nach der geburt alle ein bis
zwei monate oder zwei bis drei monate
gesehen und dann halbjährlich und dann
jährlich sie haben wachstum untersucht
den schlaf die verdauung motorik und
sprache
und daraus ist eine ungeheure sammlung
an akten entstanden an datenmaterial das
da habe ich so weit ich weiß noch nicht
mal alles ausgewertet ist gibt es ganz
naiv gefragt eine haupterkenntnis die
sie aus diesen unzähligen akten aus
diesem material gezogen haben ja also es
gibt natürlich einige einsichten aber
was muss mich schon auch dann sehr
nachdenklich und demütig gestimmt hat
ist das im grunde genommen die kinder
sich selber entwickeln wollen und wir
ständig daran sind sich rannten sie
daran zu hindern das ist für mich das
größte problem also die kinder die haben
einen enormen 30 zu entwickeln und wir
wir machen planwirtschaft oder wird
ihren eine vorstellung wie dann unser
kind einmal sein soll und woran die
schule die gesellschaft die wirtschaft
die die die normiert auf eine art und
weise die eben dann den einzelnen
kindlich gericht wird nun das gleiche
passiert auch in der wirtschaft und das
ist schon das ist doch ein wunder also
wenn man den kindern zuschaut wie sich
die entwickeln und eben dabei auch wurde
das geht so nicht die erfahrungen immer
die erfahrungen suchen die sie brauchen
was für erfahrungen sind können wir
eigentlich nicht bestimmen sondern das
kind braucht die erfahrung die ist einen
aktuellen entwicklungsstand entspricht
und wir wir vertrauen den kindern nicht
nur wir glauben viel zu wenig daran dass
das sich die kinder mit all ihren formen
entwickeln und dass sie lernen und wenn
meine elfjährige tochter jetzt unbedingt
die ganze zeit am ipad und dem iphone
spielen möchte machen lassen also das
spannen die ist ja heißt ist ein großes
problem oder für viele natürlich auch
das spannende ist doch eigentlich sich
zu fragen warum machen dies ging das
muss offensichtlich so sein dass das
interessante ist ja und da habe ich
starke eindrücke einfach das bewegt sich
bilder die farben töne auskommt der
sollte daran fahren oder also ich denke
vor der pubertät ist dass frauen so dass
das dass sie die spiele interessieren
die sind eine herausforderung
einfachste spiel sie müssen nicht einmal
figuren ausgearbeitet seien einfach eine
herausforderung wie schaffe ich jetzt
dass das ich einverstanden
das ist eben auch dieser drive oder den
sich die menschen erhoben haben in den
letzten 200 tausend jahren
und zwar deshalb weil sie wenn sie die
umwelt besser verstanden haben dann
haben sie auch besser überlebt
und dieser drang setzt sich in der
entwicklung der letzten 150 jahre fort
oder und das eines der probleme haben
wir das wir natürlich nie zufrieden sind
oder also hören auf dem mars und wir
wollen in den nanobereich setzt sich
immer vor
das ist auch der mensch neue jahre ja
aber wenn es natürlich dann dazu kommt
dass man die atombombe findet dann haben
wir das problem dass wir das diese diese
bedrohung auch kontrollieren müssen und
das ist in der gesundheit so das ist
eigentlich überall so oder also müssten
im grunde genommen uns diesen diesen
drang verstehen zu müssen
die welt verstehen zu müssen da sind wir
die einzigen lebewesen kitas haben wenn
sie sagen das unterscheidet uns von
ihren auto ist ein ein aspekt aber aber
dieser drang oder den team müssen wir
endlich mal ernst nähmen akzeptieren hat
viel wunderbares geschaffen
keine frage aber es hat ein
gewaltpotenzial drin dass das wissen wie
real oder das enorm ist und diese
endpunkte entwicklung fängt ja ganz früh
an sie haben das gesagt die neugierde
und was ist so faszinierend finde jetzt
im rückblick auf dieses eine jahr mit
mit der kleinen tochter
dass so etwas abläuft wie ein
biologisches programm das irgendwann
können die plötzlich greifen dann
krabbeln dann fängt sie hoffentlich
irgendwann anzusprechen und man muss
auch nichts dazu tun sondern es kommt
irgendwann der nächste schritt man weiß
nicht in einer wand dafür plädieren sie
ja auch in ihren büchern und sagen es
gibt nicht den zeitpunkt sondern die
kinder sind unterschiedlich und sie
haben einen läuft so mitgebracht und
anhand von dem können sie sehr gut
zeigen welche entwicklungsschritte ein
kind in den ersten monaten und jahren
macht die haben hier noch ein paar
bilder dazu
vielleicht könnte ich das kurz erklärt
das kenne ja alle eltern nach einem
leben ohne also ab so vier bis sechs
monaten fügten sie ihr kind wie hier ein
enkelkind von mir und das kind lernt so
den lösungen und dann einige monate
später ist das kind module so weit
entwickelt dass es selber essen will und
das ist jetzt zum beispiel so eine
leistung auf die ein neunmonatiges
klingt unglaublich stolz sportskanonen
also ich kann mit dem lösung ist und es
fängt ganz ganz viel kann man jetzt
sagen war das anfängt ja so mit neun bis
zwölf monaten aber es ist wiederum vom
team zu klingt extrem unterschiedlich
und dann geschieht etwas ganz
wunderbares das schafft kein lebewesen
mit dem zu 15 bis 18 monaten kann sich
das kind vorstellen ich es jetzt nicht
mehr nur mit der prüfung sondern ich
füttere die pad sowie die mama mich
getötet ohne gene und und dass das ist
eine erweiterung in dem sinne dass das
kind sich bis zu einem gewissen grad aus
ein selbständiges wesen erfasst ich bin
nicht gewissermaßen deshalb auch ich
will und auf der anderen seite dass es
sich vorstellen kann
die puppe ist eigentlich auch ein wesen
und das täglich dafür kurz dazwischen
fragen ist das auch rollenspiel also
spielt das ist der ball ging ja die
perspektiven übernahme ich spielte es
die mutter und weitere dass die gene das
ist der beginn des spiels das dann im
laufe der jahre immer
mehr ausdifferenziert wird und dann
somit etwa zwei jahren geschieht etwas
unglaubliches weiteres unglaubliches das
kind kann sich vorstellen dass die puppe
jetzt selber ist mit dem iphone
das hat eine vorstellung löffel ist eine
vorstellung was essen bedeutet hat eine
vorstellung die puppe dann bringt es
dass das möglich und zugleich lernt es
auch die entsprechenden worte also das
ding da heißt ein löffel und was ich da
mache ist es also es wird dann
eingebunden gewissermaßen diese
vorstellungen eingebunden in die sprache
und so zwischen 52 zwischen 24 und 30
monaten ist dann das kind fähig eine
szene wie hier also die familie ist nach
zu spielen und zu stehen
und da geht es ja der entschuldigung
da geht es ja nicht nur darum dass jetzt
die eltern und die beiden kinder ist
sondern das kind hat auch eine klare
vorstellung wo jedes sitzt
das ist die wiederholung der ausstellung
wie eben der familientisch aussieht zu
hause ich weiß auch wie die täler und
die tasten und so weiter wo sie
hingehören an einem tisch also das kind
hat bereits eine sehr gute vorstellung
vom raum
das weiß also zum beispiel besteht neben
dem dinner die füße die schuhe unter dem
tisch und so weiter und das verbindet es
dann wieder mit der sprache also in dem
sinn dass es dann diese begriffe auch
versteht also die
präposition wie auch unter oder neben
oder verurteilt
es ist wirklich faszinierend am anfang
können die ja fast nichts und dann mit
16 und 18 sind sie fast erwachsene ja
selber was ist für sie persönlich wenn
sie auch diese entwicklungsschritte im
detail kennen
der meilenstein der menschwerdung oder
des erwachsenwerdens
ich denke es gibt keinen punkt sondern
es ist der weg und sich also vieles zum
beispiel vorstellungen vom raum
das haben höhere entwickelte tiere auch
oder also der seite und war es sehr
genau wo es eine nische versteckt hat
aber was was so der punkt ist beim
menschen ist dass er nicht nur die
vorstellung hat sondern dass die
vorstellung unabhängig wird von der
erfahrung was wir können dann über etwas
sprechen zukunft weihnachten des jahres
oder wo wir in die ferien gehen
das eigentlich völlig unabhängig ist von
der unmittelbaren situation oder den
erfahrungen die wir machen und das ist
schon das ist schon einmal aber aber
diese entwicklung die geht dann nicht
über das ganze leben oder was man kann
nicht sagen da ist ein punkt wo es dann
definitiv entscheiden was man sieht ja
so das fängt schon mit zwei jahren an
mit fähigkeiten die kein anderes tier
und sie würden ja sagen was uns
vertrauen von den tieren unterscheiden
ist diese zweck klose neugierde also wir
sind einfach neu gegen möchten ich
verstehe die tiere sind ja auch sehr
neugierig aber sie wollen immer etwas
nicht geht zum beispiel eine beute
fangen oder die pflanze finden
die man essen kann aber wir haben das
dass die unglaubliche neugier an sich
also und und außerdem kommt zum beispiel
dann auch ja kommen viele kulturelle
entwicklungen also zum beispiel wo nicht
nur essen sondern wie gestalten das ist
wie kochen wir tischen auf ihren
kreationen die ersetzung jahr
sie sagen ja zur beruhigung viele eltern
jedes kind will lernen
ich habe mich gefragt machen warum die
wahrscheinlich auch das falsche lernen
also das ipad zum beispiel gewesen oder
gegen welche gewaltspiele computerspiele
gibt das nicht her dass ein kind
neugierig auf das was ist das ihm nicht
gut tut
das meinen also nochmals ein tablet oder
beim ipad sowie wir müssen uns auch
fragen warum ist das so interessant und
ich habe das schon ausgeführt für die
kleineren kinder und wenn die wenn wenn
sie dann in die pubertät kommen dann ist
das in einem hohen maß an
kommunikationsmitteln und wenn man sich
diese gespräche an hört oder liest dann
ist es doch so dass da nicht wahnsinnig
wichtige inhalte mitgeteilt werden
sondern es geht hauptsächlich darum
beziehungen aufzunehmen und das ist aber
jetzt ein riesiges problem wenn wenn
wenn die tochter mit zwölf jahren aber
eine im zimmer sitzt dann will sie mit
ihrer freundin sprechen wäre die
freundin tag als hätten wir eine andere
gestaltung unseres sozialen raumes dann
wäre das gar nicht nötig also vieles
wird mit den modernen medien kompensiert
was eigentlich im alltag einfach aber
schaffen ist aber auf fragen wie diese
weise kompensiert könnte man ja sagen
also sie haben das bedürfnis nach
gemeinschaft nach beziehung auch das
bedürfnis sich zu vergleichen zum
beispiel aber dann kommen soziale
netzwerke wie facebook
undsoweiter instagram wo man sich auch
permanent vergleicht aber wo dann der
selbstwert meistens in keller sinkt weil
man sich die ganze zeit an diesen
idealen vorstellungen der anderen und
von sich selbst misst also die die
frustration ist ja das gilt ja nicht nur
jetzt
das gilt auch für den konsum über die
schwierigkeit ist doch also ich ziehe
jetzt ein neues kleid das gerade mode
gekommen ist der auf die strasse h
die menschen reagieren dann ist aber
bereits vorbei
also diese diese attraktivität die
soziale anerkennung die man bekommt oder
auf facebook also irgendwo in sozialer
medien
das ist immer nur momentan und was uns
eben fehlt das ist eine
lebensgemeinschaft wo man eben dann auf
längere zeit ihn eine feste stellung hat
eine feste beziehung genau und und
soziale anerkennung fehlt und sehr
vieles in unserer gesellschaft ist im
grunde genommen ein kompensations
verhalten also die die soziale medien
die unterhaltung natürliche ihrer auch
nicht und und eben auch der konsum
das klingt sehr kulturkritisch wollen
sie die zeit zurückdrehen
ich gebe lieber eine antwort was kultur
ursprünglich war also wenn man wie man
schaut wie das wirklich während
mindestens 200.000 jahren war so war die
die kultur eigentlich ein kit für die
lebensgemeinschaft also man hat zusammen
gesungen man hat zusammen getanzt
man hat in einer bestimmten weise
miteinander gegessen man halt
wertvorstellungen geschaffen die man
geteilt hat
und dass das hat die die
lebensgemeinschaft hat das
zusammengebracht
wenn man die kultur heute anschaut dann
würde ich sagen diese funktion ist
komplett verloren gegangen
und das ist das problem was wir als
kultur bezeichnen das sind das in der
literatur oder sei das in der musik
überall aber aber es bringt die menschen
nicht zusammen oder also wenn man wie
man zum beispiel zusammen sind oder
zusammen musiziert ist das etwas ganz
anderes als wenn ich an ein pop konzert
gehen beziehungsweise weil man in dieser
masse untergeht und vereinsamt und sowas
und schwingt mit emotional oder
gefühlsmäßig schwingt man mit und aber
das reicht euch das zu anonymen würden
sie sagen wir nein das beziehung ist ein
ständiges eine ständige
auseinandersetzung und nicht ein eine
einbahnstraße und die kultur würde ich
behaupten haben
was ist für sie eigentlich das ziel
einer guten erziehung
also wir können uns fragen wie möchten
wir dass unsere tochter oder unser sohn
ist wenn er mal 20 ist ne
und dann möchten wir doch im grunde
genommen ein kind das seine
grundbedürfnisse befriedigen hat
befriedigen können während der ganzen
kleinteil tun also fragen was
geborgenheit dann betrifft und dann
möchten wir ein kind das seine
fähigkeiten entwickeln konnte und dann
und das vergisst man allzu leicht
möchten wir ein kind das ein gutes
selbstwertgefühl hat und eine gute
selbstwirksamkeit selbstwirksamkeit was
heißt das 63 und beides ist keine
fähigkeit an sich sondern eine erfahrung
also selbst bestimmt heisst ich konnte
meinen interessen und bedürfnissen
nachgehen ich habe diese erfahrung
gemacht
selbstwirksamkeit heißt ich kann in
dieser welt etwas bewirken und so selbst
selbstbestimmt und das ist zb weiter in
der erziehung und ganz sicher in der
schule kaum mehr der fall also dass das
ein schüler wird eigentlich immer
miteinander mit einer aufgabe muss eine
aufgabe lösen also er ist eigentlich in
einem hohen maße fremdbestimmt jetzt
rechnen wir oder jetzt lesen wir
und dann sage ich dir gleich noch welche
aufgabe grüßt die sonst oder warst du
lesen aber das muss ein kind doch auch
lernen weil eine gesellschaft später ist
ja auch wir leben in einer
leistungsgesellschaft und die
anforderungen kommen von außen und man
muss das können erziehung könnte man
auch sagen hat das ziel die kinder auf
die gesellschaft vorzubereiten so wie
sie eben gerade ist ja also wenn man
wirklich die worden
selbst akzeptiert dann kann man so
argumentieren
das problem ist nur dass in der
wirtschaft wird beklagt dass die jungen
menschen keine initiative haben dass sie
eigentlich nicht zu hungern
die kommen und fragen was muss ich jetzt
tun in der schule oder das ist absolut
verheerend
auch die kreativität wird so vernichtet
oder meine kreativität um nur nicht als
aufgaben sondern indem man suchen selber
herausfindet was man jetzt schöpferisch
erbringen würde also nein das ist das in
einer gewissen weise ist das eine
vergewaltigung des wesens und das was
sie gesagt haben das ist der klassiker
als einwand nicht der punkt ist einfach
jedes kind lesen jedes kind will rechnen
jedes kind will alles was später braucht
das problem ist nur sind wir zufrieden
damit
also dann und auslesen oder überfordern
wir essen stern höhere erwartungen und
da dann entmutigen
das kind und am schluss auf mehreren
erwachsenen der sich fremdbestimmt fühlt
und dann schlechter selbstwertgefühl
das klingt für mich so wirklich nach
einem romantischen erziehungs ideal ich
bin überhaupt kein erziehungsexperte das
klingt so hasst als wäre alles gut was
von innen kommt und alles irgendwie
verdächtig oder schlecht das von außen
kommt primär kommt alles von ihnen aber
was ja die umwelt dem kind und auch den
erwachsenen vermittelt ist der inhalte
zum beispiel phuket zu hören die sprache
wie wie hoch die sprachkompetenz eines
kindes ist das kommt nur von ihnen nicht
darum
aber der inhalt des brauchen die kunden
aber zum beispiel moral und ethik
gewisse grundregeln wenn jetzt meine
kleine tochter dann in einem jahr zu den
anderen kindern geht und die schlägt und
mit den gemein ist dann kann ich nicht
sagen das ist die innere drang ich lasse
sich jetzt mal machen sondern man muss
diesen auch in einer kultur groß sind
mit bestimmten werten vertraut machen
aber auch fähigkeiten beibringen eben
wie eine eigene sprache oder wie
mathematik und dadurch hat sie eine
höhere auch nicht von freiheit alles
alles was wir machen müssen ist kommt
noch auf das auf die moral zurück
aber alles was im grunde genau wo man
machen müssen ist die umwelt die umwelt
so gestalten dass das kind die
entsprechende erfahrungen machen konnte
ist das ist alles also könnte das geht
die zweite aber ich kenne eine schule
die macht das seit 30 jahren das
funktioniert bist und jetzt mit bezug
auf die moral oder das schlagen andere
kinder
wir meinen wir müssen dem kind soziale
regeln bei bringen also zum beispiel
kann man einen 23 jährigen sagen du
solltest jetzt den routen nicht schlagen
weil das du weißt ja das tut weh
das problem ist einfach das kind weiß
nicht dass das andere weh tut das ist
nicht so weit ist es mit perioden dafür
aber der viel wichtigere punkt ist die
kinder werden letztlich erzogen über das
vorbild nicht das was wir ihnen sorgen
sondern wirklich was wir ihnen vorleben
also wenn die eltern zum beispiel
sorgsam mit der katze umgehen dann wird
das kind das zwangsläufig auch machen
man muss nicht sagen du musst jetzt lieb
sein mitbekommen sind also das ist auch
ein biologisches erbe das zur
sozialisierung für den der in dem das
kind eine tiefe bereitschaft hat nach
zusammen so zu werden wie seine eltern
oder auch größere ging deswegen sagt der
kabarettist
karl valentin wir brauchen unsere kinder
nicht zu erziehen sie machen uns sowieso
außer acht lassen sie uns jetzt gegen
schluss noch ein bisschen über diese
gesellschaftlichen dimension sprechen
sie zitieren ja gerne ein afrikanisches
sprichwort das heißt es braucht ein
ganzes dorf um ein kind großzuziehen ist
dass damit gemeint das was sie gesagt
haben dass wir wieder diese
lebensgemeinschaften brauchen und was
würde das konkret heißen für unsere
gesellschaft bräuchten wir
mehrgenerationenhäuser zum beispiel
müssten wir alten und pflegeheime
abschaffen und uns wieder gemeinsam
betreuen müssen wir schauen dass die
eltern und großeltern und tanten wieder
ungefähr im selben ort leben was
bedeutet das konkret
also vieles von dem was wir bereits
gesagt haben aber ich möchte eben noch
etwas darauf eingehen was was unser
problem ist heute also wir überschätzen
als erstes die familie in der
vergangenheit dort hatte die familie nie
die bedeutung die wir heute zu messen
sondern es war frauen die
lebensgemeinschaft und da sind wir auch
wir überlebt andere verwandte oder auch
nachbar natürlich gab es dann in der
lebensgemeinschaft gab es natürlich
unterschiede ne unterschiedliche grade
von beziehungen
das gab es schon aber diese
ausschließlichkeit die wir heute der
familie geben und dann erst noch der
kleine familie vater mutter ein kind
oder vielleicht auch ein weiteres dass
das ist eigentlich eine eine
überforderung also wenn ich verstehe
eltern wenn sie sagen nicht nur wegen
der arbeit und frauen für die für die
frauen auch die mutter diete spagat
zwischen beruf und familie
nein es ist eine überforderung das ist
nicht so gedacht und es gibt zwei
probleme punkte erstens einmal braucht
das kind andere bezugspersonen
es lernt sehr viel von anderen
bezugspersonen
die eltern können nicht alles abdecken
also zum beispiel hat man eine nachbar
der der hat eine schreinerwerkstatt der
vater interessiert das überhaupt nicht
nur aber das kind wenn es interessiert
ist an die geht es um nachbarn und das
andere was extrem wichtig ist und heute
wirklich ein problem
kinder sind ausnahmslos mit anderen
kindern aufgewachsen
sie lernen extrem viel von den anderen
kindern also wenn man jetzt schaut
kinder die in kitas gehen und kinder die
allein in einer kleinfamilie anwachsen
vielleicht sieht einen bruder oder eine
schwester oder ganz allein reicht
oftmals auch nicht aber über die hälfte
ist es nur ein kind oder und wenn man
jetzt schaut wie weit sind die wenn sie
in den kindergarten eindrücken ist ein
enormer unterschied die empfehlen sehr
viele erfahrungen die sie gut oder
andere kinder machen können fragen
sprachlich und sozial aber auch in
anderen bereich zb mode oder wenn eine
gruppe von kindern in der wiese sitzen
einer rennt los das ist unwiderstehlich
darin der unterlagen aber ein kind
allein in der walliser sitzt oder wie
soll es jetzt los wenn es überhaupt in
der wiese sitzen und nicht im
kinderzimmer also ihre einsichten haben
konkrete folgerungen für die
familienpolitik auch in der schweiz sie
sagen die schweiz ist kein
kinderfreundliches land und vergleichen
das oft mit finnland oder die
skandinavischen ländern wo dreimal mehr
geld für familien und kinder ausgegeben
wird
aber es ist auch eine zeitdiagnose die
sie eigentlich fragen wir hatten das
ganz am anfang schon was sie gesagt
haben diese anonyme massen gesellschaft
die globalisierung die modernisierung
das ist eine überforderung und sie
führen auch bestimmte konservative
reaktionär
politische tendenzen darauf zurück und
schreiben das sind kollektiv
unbefriedigte grundbedürfnisse ja das
waren nicht dort aus spannt
also ich würde meinen was jetzt so
abgeht auch mit gramm oder oder serie
jetzt mit makro dass wir total spannend
oder
und so meine ich das so also ich hab das
ursprünglich eigentlich ein buch
schreiben will dass die die politischen
parteien verschwinden werden ich habe
nicht gedacht dass es so ausgeht und das
spannende ist man kann keine politik
machen in den politischen parteien deren
grund sei irgendwo vor 150 jahren
definiert wurden sind eine löbliche
ausnahmen sind die grünen haben sonst
ist es so und eigentlich ist eine gute
politik die die sich an der gruppe d
fließen der menschen orientiert konkret
heißt aus wie gut ist die
gesundheitsversorgung wie geborgen
fühlen sich die menschen und welches
soziale anerkennung brauchen sie und
dazu würde ich meinen braucht ist die
lebensgemeinschaft aber dann leben wir
in einer welt nur globaler wettbewerb
herrscht und es kann sein dass wir dann
nicht mehr so leistungsfähig sind
das wachstum abnimmt wir werden
abgehängt das sind die konsequenzen
ja das ist also so wurde eigentlich die
entwicklung in den letzten 150 jahren
bestimmt oder und diese diese grausame
angst abgehängt zu werden
die konnten auch schon daher dass dass
wir einen drang haben uns möglichst gut
sozial abzusichern
mein früher war das oft gar nicht
möglich ja aber ich denke alle sind
damit einverstanden dass es so nicht
weitergehen kann oder also her wissen
sie das als beispiel
wir brauchen ein einkommen
dass wir immer weniger gewährleistet
sein
es waren frauen wegen der
digitalisierung
es gibt es ein ganz neues schönes
beispiel
nike hat holly seine betriebe nach außen
verlagert weil dort die löhne für die
vorauswahl billig jetzt kommen sie
zurück aber nicht um die menschen hier
zu beschäftigen sondern es sind gruppen
zum schluss eine ganz kurze frage das
passende leben ist das auch das
sinnvolle leben ich würde ja weil wir
mit allen fonds und danach streben aber
man sollte das nicht das ziel ansehen
sondern ausweg er lag ganz herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch gespielt und
kann mich bringen und sehen sie nächsten
donnerstag bereits wieder an auffahrt
dann erwartet sich hier eine wahre
sternstunde meine kollegin barbara
bleisch trifft sich mit dem
astrophysiker ben nur zur
philosophischen odyssee durchs wert auch
wenn man glaubt zwar nicht an gott aber
ist überzeugt dass es irgendwo da
draußen noch ein anderes leben gibt und
jetzt gleich starten wir mit einer
entdeckungstour durch das europäische
kino die reihe sinne kino taucht ein in
das filmschaffen von fünf ländern den
auftakt heute macht frankreich das land
das das kino auf der ganzen welt immer
wieder entscheidend geprägt hat
genießen sie den sonntag und verpassen
sie nicht das passende leben
[Musik]